prise d'otages à l'ambassade de pologne
en suisse le commando aux des conditions
politiques solidarité condamne
l'opération ce mardi à fès unité de
façade autour de yasser arafat
la politique économique et sociale du
gouvernement après les déclarations du
premier ministre
réactions mitigées des syndicats la
rentrée la rentrée des classes c'est
pour demain dans la majeure partie de la
foule même monsieur bonsoir pour la
première fois en neuf mois d'état de
siège
le drame polonais a débordé de ses
frontières
en effet depuis ce matin l'ambassade de
pologne à berne
là bien tranquille capitale fédérale de
la suisse l'ambassade de pologne est
occupé par un commando lourdement armé
qui se réclame d'un mystérieux front de
libération populaire polonais tout de
suite les faits sylvie marion depuis une
dizaine d'heures maintenant on ne sait
toujours pas ce qui se passe dans cette
maison entourée d'un jardin dans le
quartier des ambassades à berne un chef
de commando a connu appartenant à un
mouvement inconnu
il est tien 8 à 10 diplomate polonais
l'ambassade de pologne tout volets
fermés est entouré d'un dispositif
policier très léger aucun mouvement les
perceptible de la rue où la circulation
continue normalement
9h50 ce matin le commando s'introduit ou
du téléphone du chef du commando à
l'agencé france presse il dit se nommer
monsieur bischoff ski il dit aussi
appartenir à l'armée des patriotes
polonais insurgés dans un ultimatum à la
municipalité de berne il fixe un délai
de 48 heures aux autorités polonaises
pour satisfaire ses revendications
ils exigent site la levée de l'état de
siège en pologne la libération de tous
les prisonniers politiques polonais la
suppression de tous les centres
d'internement et l'arrêt de la pression
exercée contre le peuple polonais le
subit chauve qui déclare détenir 25 kg
de dynamite et plusieurs mitrailleuses
lourdes
il fera dit il s'il le faut sauter le
bâtiment et avec lui les otages et son
commando
l'hymne est l'inconnu bishop's qui sont
prises très au sérieux par les autorités
helvétiques et polonaise oui la pologne
exige des autorités suisses le
rétablissement du fonctionnement normal
de son ambassade
c'est en tout cas la première action à
l'étranger visant le pouvoir polonais si
l'on excepte quelques détournements
d'avion opéré individuellement par des
polonais qui voulaient fuir le pays
cette fois il s'agit manifestement d'une
opération organisée qui s'apparente aux
prises d'otages en terrain diplomatique
qui se sont multipliés récemment de
l'amérique latine à l'iran et cette
opération les représentants du syndicat
solidarité en exil la dénonce
catégoriquement
même si l'ultimatum est bien de nature
politique
un représentant de solidarité à paris il
explique à michel trilogie si déjà à
midi les vivres des solidarnosc à
l'étranger rapporte elle a diffusé en
communiquant des approuvant ces types
d'actions pourquoi désapprouvez-vous ce
type d'action et bien si on nous ne
sommes pas contre l'exigence de ses
commandos c'est pour les mêmes raisons
nous existons l uta lit-on mais avec
complètement l'autre méthode nous sommes
contre l'utilisation des forces nous
sont contre méthodes terroristes
sm c'est la méthode qui ne pouvons pas
approuver accepter le chef du commando
qui s'y qui dit s'appeler le colonel
vish qui a précisé lui-même qu'il dirige
une organisation paramilitaire
anticommuniste sans aucun lien dit-il
avec solidarité ou avec l'organisation
dissidente intellectuelle le corps à
varsovie pas de réaction officielle même
si la télévision polonaise vient de
faire état de l'événement sur place le
correspondant de l afp
michel tondre à l'étranger dans le
courant de l'après midi
la présentatrice a également fait état
de ces prises d'otages avec une presse
correspondance d'un journaliste polonais
et à l'instant sur noté l'ex est tombé
la première réaction officielle
finalement que des vêtements une petite
opposition du minitel étrangères qui
déclare avoir convoqué l'ambassadeur de
suite leur survie s est remis
immédiatement sans rapport avec les
autorités helvétiques à berne
fonctionnement normal l'ambassade
premier interne soit rétabli dans les
meilleurs délais que la protection du
personnel soit assurée aujourd'hui les
dirigeants polonais au complet ont
célébré les obsèques de leur ancien
patron gomulka dont la disparition avait
été quelque peu éclipsé par les
événements dramatiques de la faim ou un
cinquième manifestant est mort à l'ubs
l'un des suites de ses blessures
aujourd'hui en france c'est vraiment la
rentrée la rentrée politique d'abord les
déclarations du premier ministre pierre
mauroy hier soir au club de la presse
d'europe 1 ont donné le ton du discours
gouvernemental pour les mois à venir
plus question des débats internes au
sein de la majorité du genre pause ou
pas pause
il s'agit maintenant dans la discipline
et la rigueur de poursuivre efficacement
la politique économique décidés par le
gouvernement et par un premier ministre
qui se dit prêt sur tous les fronts a
assumé son rôle de paratonnerre de
l'action gouvernementale
voyons d'abord les mesures concrètes
annoncées par monsieur mauroy en matière
de prix et de salaires avant de passer
aux réactions que les syndicats ont
exprimé aujourd'hui philippe sassier et
martin glissant la sortie du blocage des
prix et des salaires s'étalera entre le
1er novembre 1982 et la fin de 83 chaque
branche professionnelle va négocier avec
le gouvernement en septembre en octobre
le calendrier et les modalités de la
sortie qui seront différentes selon les
secteurs
en ce qui concerne les salaires 6 points
à retenir plus d'indexation des salaires
sur les prix
partant des objectifs de prix 8% l'an
prochain
les accords salariaux comporteront un
calendrier précis de toutes les choses
qui auront
lieu en 1983 lors de la renégociation
des accords de cette année perturbée ou
rendu caduc par le blocage
la hausse des salaires sur la période
novembre 82 à décembre 83 ne pourra pas
en moyenne dépasser la hausse prévue des
prix le maintien du pouvoir d'achat
moyen reste l'objectif du gouvernement
il faut qu'à la fin de 1983 en moyenne
toujours le pouvoir d'achat en niveau
soit préservée la première euros de
salaire consécutive au blocage doit être
limitée dans le secteur public par
exemple elle n'excédera pas 3%
la priorité est accordée aux bas
salaires soit rattrapage rapide du
retard du pouvoir d'achat soit
améliorations sur longue période pouvoir
l'achat des hauts salaires lorsque la
rémunération annuelle dépasse 250 mille
francs
la partie de rémunération qui est au
dessus de ce plafond est gelé ce
dispositif a suscité une certaine
réserve des syndicats du côté des
critiques voire des très critique
la cftc et fo et les cadres de la cgc
la centrale chrétienne la cftc regrette
je cite la perte du pouvoir d'achat des
salariés et nous prévoit une rentrée
difficile
andré bergeron pour fo redoute lui que
l'extrême rigueur du plan n'entraîne un
angle beaucoup plus important de
chômeurs quant à paul marchelli pour la
cgc
il déclare carrément que le premier
ministre ne sait pas ce qu'il veut avait
moins critique mais déçu quand même
elles m'ont l'air le secrétaire général
de la cfdt
je crois que les salariés resteront
souvent sur leur faim prévendre du
premier ministre est que les inquiétudes
sur le pouvoir d'achat
l'emploi ou les liens de la sécurité
sociale ne seront pas levées si on prend
par exemple les salaires il est clair
que même si à 20 83
en moyenne le niveau des dessins ont
rattrapé celui des prix il ya baisse de
pouvoir d'achat
82 et à qui est ce que valait cette
baisse de pouvoir d'achat
si ça vaut spycker comme ses premiers
aux bas salaires et à l'investissement
productif bon cela soutiendra l'emploi
si par contre cela va dans les caisses
des entreprises qui en feront ce
qu'elles voudront
alors ce sera cela sera négatif de même
sur la durée du travail et du travail on
nous avons l'impression qu'il y à une
sorte de d'hésitation du premier
ministre après avoir dit 35 heures aux
85 qu'il est là à dire que peut-être on
verra suivant l'opinion des travailleurs
excusez nous avons l'impression de me
pose là la cgt réagira officiellement
demain à pantin lors du meeting de
rentrée d'henri krasucki mais
aujourd'hui rue lafayette
on se réjouissait je cite du maintien de
cap affiché par le premier ministre en
soulignant qu'on était guère
enthousiaste quant à la question clé du
pouvoir d'achat quant au cnpf
il ne le dit pas dès demain c'est sûr
mais il ne déclare pas non plus la
guerre
vous avez remarqué qu'il a oublié
d'abord de parler de la répercussion
éventuelle du prix des matières
premières importées l'énergie importée
dans les plans de son entreprise qui
actuellement double flux tenir et randa
pet
deuxièmement il est vrai d'une
motivation très importante pour nos
entrepreneurs à l'heure actuelle ce la
suppression matt fois répétées de
l'impossible outil de travail qui va
condamner un grand nombre d'entreprises
françaises dans les mois qui viennent
nous avons toujours dit que comme pour
la lutte contre le chômage
nous aurons le jeu mais nous
rappellerons à la sab le mans que la vie
des entreprises est actuellement
compromise par des mesures qui ne sont
pas privés qui sont très graves
réactions aussi sur le plan politique le
parti socialiste se félicite de la
continuité de la politique
gouvernementale
le rpr par la voix de son secrétaire
général bernard pons dans notre journal
de 13h aujourd'hui affirme qu'il ne
s'agit plus d'une politique socialiste
mais d'une politique d'austérité
le rpr prépare un plan de redressement
qui sera annoncé en janvier pour
alimenter la campagne des municipales
mais revenons à la réalité économique
telle que la vivent en ce moment
concrètement des milliers d'entreprises
en france
quelles sont les réactions aux mesures
annoncées par monsieur mauroy dans une
entreprise de la banlieue parisienne
l'enquète de jean-louis calmejane dans
cette entreprise moyenne qui emploie 130
personnes
on distribue on importe est on fabrique
aussi des outils des produits pour
l'artisanat les loisirs et les travaux
manuels à partir d'ici plus de huit
mille articles différents sont
distribués un peu partout en france et à
l'étranger
la sortie du blocage des prix pose deux
problèmes à cette entreprise
d'abord savoir quel prix pratiqués après
le 1er novembre
pour ces huit mille articles ensuite
renégocier les salaires des employés
après avoir reçu les directives des
branches professionnelles de problèmes
qu'on espère pouvoir résoudre ici cette
année nous avions essayé de tenir les
10% dans recommandations de monsieur de
l'or nous avons pas pu les tenir
l'inflation a été trop forte mais nous
sommes tout disposés à retenter
l'expérience cette année est attablé
bâtir nos budgets sur une inflation des
hausses de prix de 8%
si bien sûr les prix que vous proposez
que sur les salaires sur les salaires ce
n'est que de notre sol ressort avec le
comité d'entreprise c'est un problème de
négociation
pour ce qui est des prix cela dépend
également du d'une conjoncture
internationale puisque certains prix
font l'objet de négociations au niveau
de bruxelles ou bien viennent de
l'étranger et dépendent de la parité du
franc avec certaines monnaies mais nous
nous efforcerons pour les employés le
problème est quelque peu différent ils
sont en effet plus préoccupées par
l'augmentation à venir de leur salaire
et au moment de la renégociation de ses
salaires le leitmotiv sera surtout ne
pas voir son pouvoir d'achat baisser
essayer de négocier à partir de début
novembre pour essayer de rattraper un
petit peu ce qu'on va perdre on a perdu
c'est d'essayer d'atteindre 10% j'espère
nous avions et 5 ennemis arma ii en juin
avant le fameux blocage
normalement vous devriez arriver à 11
ans et demi il faudra arriver au moins
dix chez rougier 15 cadres travaillent
et s'associe pleinement à la bonne
marche de l'entreprise
ce qui est souvent le cas dans le
secteur privé pour eux le problème de la
sortie du blocage des salaires ne
devraient pas se poser de la même
manière que pour les cadres qui
travaillent dans le secteur public
car ils estiment souvent moins motivé je
suis tout à fait d'accord pour l'effort
national
concernant le
le blocage des salaires
par contre je pense que un cadre a
besoin quand même d'une certaine
motivation et
cette motivation ne peut se concevoir
que par le par le salaire or
l'indexation de 8% risque à mon avis
deux peut-être de limiter un petit peu 7
cette volonté chez les cadres reste à
savoir comment cette entreprise qui se
veut avoir l'esprit pme et dont les
dirigeants les cadres et les employés
semble rempli de bonne volonté va
concrètement sortir du blocage des prix
et des salaires question que se posent
aujourd'hui ces mêmes dirigeants cadres
et employés
autres projets annoncés hier soir par
monsieur mauroy sur europe 1 un projet
qui doit compléter le dispositif de
lutte anti chômage
le service militaire pour être enrôlé
des jeunes gens des 18 ans afin
d'éponger l'afflux de jeunes sur le
marché du travail
la mesure viserait quelque 80000
conscrits pharand autres gros dossiers
de la politique économique et social le
financement de l'assurance chômage
à partir de demain les partenaires
sociaux vont commencer une nouvelle
série de rencontres pour trouver une
solution
le président du cnpf yvon gattaz qui a
été reçu aujourd'hui par le ministre de
la solidarité des affaires sociales
monsieur bérégovoy pour parler
essentiellement de la sécurité sociale
monsieur gattaz a déjà indiqué que le
cnpf refuserait toute augmentation des
cotisations des salariés et des
entreprises
laurence graff avec le refus énergie du
patronat d'augmenter les cotisations
une des hypothèses évoquées pour
financer les déficits du système chômage
semble sérieusement compromise
les hypothèses il y en a beaucoup
lesquels seront adoptées là il faut être
prudent
la réunion de demain matin mais que la
première d'une série de quatre prévues
pour septembre
alors les choses peuvent changer le
problème lui il est clair il faut
combler un déficit évalué à 37 milliards
d'ici fin 1983 pour cela trois
possibilités sont évoquées
la première faire des économies en
réduisant les dépenses
on parle par exemple d'un délai de
carence c'est à dire d'un décalage entre
l'arrêt de travail et le début des
allocations chômage décalage
correspondant à la période d'indemnités
de licenciements ou de congés payés par
exemple
deuxièmement augmenter les recettes
c'est la contribution solidarité prévue
pour les fonctionnaires en principe à
partir du 1er novembre et pour les
autres commerçants professions libérales
à partir du 1er janvier tout cela ne
suffisant pas l'hypothèse d'une
cotisation patronale
et salariale est quand même toujours
évoquée troisième possibilité sortir du
budget de l'unedic pour les mettre au
budget de l'état
tout ce qui n'est pas allocations
chômage essentiellement ce qu'on appelle
la garantie de ressources pré retraite
qui doit disparaître
ultérieurement mais qui est très
coûteuse pour l'instant un tiers du
budget de l'unedic
bref l'état qui subventionne déjà
l'unedic est prêt à intervenir pour
pousser ou pour aider les partenaires
sociaux mais seulement quand il sera
jusqu'où ils sont décidés à les
cartables les plumiers sont prêts ce
soir en principe c'est demain la rentrée
des classes pour plus de 10 millions
d'élèves français à l'exception des
académies de la région parisienne de
montpellier et de la corse
à cette occasion plus de 2 millions de
familles vont toucher une allocation de
rentrée scolaire de quelques 260 francs
pour encourager les élèves mais aussi
les enseignants a démarré d'un bon pied
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
alain savary dans une lettre aux
instituteurs et aux professeurs
encourage les initiatives et les
recherches éducative au sein de chaque
établissement
les français ont d'ailleurs une bonne
opinion du personnel d'enseignement si
l'on en croit un sondage publié par
l'hebdomadaire la vie plus de la moitié
des français considèrent que les
enseignants sont bien préparés à leur
métier et qui dresse des privilégiés
l'état d'esprit des enseignant dans un
lycée des environs de lyon dominique
lose c'est devenu une tradition depuis
une dizaine d'années les instituteurs et
les professeurs rentrer un jour avant
les élèves une journée consacrée à
l'organisation du travail la mise en
place de l'emploi du temps et pour les
nouveaux la découverte de
l'établissement dans lequel ils vont
exercer pendant un an
on commence par commenter les vacances
puis on passe rapidement au social
l'élément clé professeur coordonnateur
des disciplines d'informer les nouveaux
collègues des habitudes de la maison et
madame le principal présente les
nouveaux professeurs nouveaux profs
parfois le mais loin de leur lieu
d'habitation
ce qui pose un certain nombre de
problèmes actuels cet après midi nous
conserverons dans l'établissement que
les professeurs des sixièmes on apprend
reçoit sa nomination fin août et on doit
être à pied d'oeuvre début septembre
avec tous les problèmes que ça pose le
pied
oui je suis marié mon mari est agronome
travail est bonne et il ne peut pas de
placer dans son métier est impossible
ils se déplacent donc maintenant il vit
à grenoble et vous avez vu ici voilà
c'est ça je suis en situation de divorce
administratif est un peu usagé région
annonce un terme qu'on emploie pour
désigner cette chose l'objectif de cette
première réunion la nouvelle circulaire
de rentrée consacrée à l'amélioration de
la vie et du climat dans les collèges
rapports entre parents enseignants et
élèves et apprentissage de l'autonomie
des enfants
ce n'est pas dans des classes de 30
qu'on va faire du travail autonome qu'on
va faire du travail de groupe ça me
paraît difficile les moyens c'est l'une
des conditions essentielles pour sortir
des difficultés du système scolaire sans
oublier une nécessaire modification des
méthodes actuelles d'encadrement et
d'enseignement 1
pour nous le problème numéro un c'est
l'échec scolaire s'aperçut que l'on peut
pas laisser les choses en l'état a donc
décidé de lutter et on n'a pas trouvé de
moyen miracle mais le travail en équipe
seront ici mise en oeuvre bref pour les
enseignants c'est de rentrée marquée par
une sensible amélioration du climat
dix sept mille postes ont été créés ne
leur fait pas oublier pour autant leur
préoccupation première
une réforme des collèges qui devrait
normalement intervenir à la rentrée 80
en attendant voyons quels sont les deux
les de la rentrée 90
avec 12 millions 700 mille élèves dont 2
millions à l'école privée la population
scolaire cette année encore est en
baisse malgré une hausse des effectifs
de maternelle 40% de ses enfants sont au
collège et au lycée
ils sont ainsi deux fois plus nombreux
qu'il y a quinze ans à fréquenter le
secondaire les enseignants eux sont plus
de 700 milles 12 milles de plus que l'an
dernier avec une forte majorité de
femmes surtout parmi les instituteurs
pour les nouveautés de cette rentrée il
faut retenir en particulier l'entrée en
application du plan 16 18 ans avec des
actions spécifiques de formation pour
cent mille jeunes sortis du système
éducatif sans qualification
les moyens de l'enseignement technique
seront renforcés après les seconde
indifférenciée les premières cd
fusionnent en une première scientifique
la première s afin de retarder une
orientation fondé jusqu alors sur les
sols mathématiques trois établissements
expérimentaux à pédagogies différentes
seront ouverts l'enseignement des
langues et des cultures régionales
recevra un début de statuts puis d'une
manière générale cette rentrée le point
de départ d'un changement dans la vie
scolaire surtout dans les collèges avec
notamment un meilleur accueil des élèves
de 6e bref une amélioration des rapports
enfants adultes un meilleur climat dans
les établissements qui à terme seront
moins dépendant de l'administration
centrale
demain antenne de midi vivra les affres
et les plaisirs de la rentrée puisque le
journal aura lieu en direct du lycée de
meyzieu près de lyon
retournons à l'étranger maintenant et
aux tourments du proche orient
ils n'ont pas levé le petit doigt pour
aider les palestiniens pendant le siège
de beyrouth mais ils étaient presque
tous là aujourd'hui à fès au maroc pour
accueillir yasser arafat comme un chef
d'état
tous c'est à dire les rois les émirs les
premiers ministres et autres dignitaires
du monde arabe réunis au maroc pour un
sommet qui commence ce soir sur place
philippe raud font les serres arafat
sera bien à la vedette de ce 12e sommet
tous les chefs d'état arabes ont en
effet accompagner ce matin-là sam 2 à
l'aéroport de fès pour accueillir le
chef de l'olp et on a même joué pour lui
l'hymne palestiniens biladi mon pays mon
pays
une manière de rendre les honneurs à
celui qu'on appelle ici le héros de la
bataille de beyrouth
et pourtant le chef de l'olp et va faire
sentir à ses frères arabes qui l'ont
abandonné pendant la bataille
la preuve il a fallu trois mois jour
pour jour après le début de l'offensive
israélienne au liban pour que se
réunisse enfin un sommet arabe
pourtant la marge de manoeuvre de yasser
arafat sera limité depuis l'évacuation
des fedayins de beyrouth
le mouvement palestinien va devenir de
plus en plus dépendant de la politique
des pays arabes et arafat pourra
difficilement leur demander des comptes
voilà pourquoi l'ol paie n'a pas
condamné la ville avant de venir en
discuter ici à fès un plan reagan qui
divise les palestiniens comme il divise
le monde arabe
d'un côté ceux qui disent non à la
simple autonomie palestinienne dans les
territoires occupés et réclame un état
de l'autre ceux qui se contenteraient de
ce plan reagan et qui sont les pays du
camp américain
l'arabie saoudite et les émirats
officiellement les chefs d'état arabes
sont venus à fès pour arrêter une
stratégie commune face à israël et
pourtant ce sont les plantes des plans
américains plantade et plan bourguiba
qui tous trois implique la
reconnaissance de l'état hébreu qui
seront au centre des débats en se
démarquant d'israël les etats-unis ont
incontestablement faciliter la tâche des
dirigeants arabes à grand renfort
d'embrassades de sémantique s'est en
effet encore une fois contre israël que
les dirigeants arabes vont s'efforcer de
cristalliser un semblant d'unité mais en
filigrane il ne faut pas oublier les
différends qui les opposent les uns aux
autres bruno albin le nombre des
participants à ces sommets de fait été
levé 20 pays représentés sur les 22 que
comptait la ligue arabe
mais les deux absents sont de taille
l'egypte et la libye du colonel kadhafi
mais surtout ce sommet rassemble autour
d'une même table les représentants de
pays dont beaucoup sont les
protagonistes de conflits armés à
l'intérieur même du monde arabe
l'irakien saddam hussein par exemple en
guerre depuis trois ans contre l'iran
une guerre qui traîne en longueur et qui
a mis en évidence le fossé séparant les
dirigeants de bagdad de ceux du régime
syrien du président ancien du président
hafez et l'afld el-assad autre
face-à-face étrange celui du souverain
marocain hassan 2 qui affirma depuis
bientôt sept ans les droits de son pays
sur l'ancien sahara espagnol et du
représentant de l'algérie de chadli
bendjedid qui soutient la lutte des
combattants de la république arabe
sahraouie contre les troupes de rabah
enfin si le motif de cette réunion et la
recherche d'une solution au problème
palestinien
il faut bien constater que yasser arafat
a pour ce sommet des interlocuteurs
divers
ces partenaires sont à fès des hommes
dont le moins que l'on puisse dire est
qu'ils ne se sont pas précipités pour
tendre à l'ol paie la planche de salut
sur laquelle on aurait pu compter
lorsque les palestiniens étaient
encerclés dans beyrouth ouest
il n'y a pas encore si longtemps la
situation au proche orient après la
guerre du liban les propositions
américaines concernant le sort de la
cisjordanie et de gaza seront donc au
coeur des discussions de fès philippe
rochot vous le disais tout à l'heure
même si on ne connaît toujours pas la
réponse officielle de l'ol paie aux
propositions reggane israël en tout cas
ne veut rien entendre proposition
irrecevable a dit hier le ministre
israélien des affaires étrangères plus
question de reprendre maintenant les
négociations sur l'autonomie
palestinienne dit on aujourd'hui à
jérusalem israël ne veut pas non plus
d'une force internationale au sud liban
le ministre israélien des affaires
étrangères l'a dit aujourd'hui aux
ambassadeurs européens jérusalem a par
ailleurs lancé un avertissement qualifié
de très grave à la syrie pour obtenir la
libération de huit soldats israéliens
enlevés samedi dernier au liban
moyen-orient toujours un navire turc a
coulé samedi dernier victimes du conflit
entre l'iran et l'irak non loin du
terminal pétrolier de l'île de kharg
irak vous le savez affirmait avoir
détruit deux pétroliers deux cargos
concrétisant ainsi sa menace militaire
sur le pétrole iranien
pourtant les milieux maritimes de
londres qui est la plaque tournante du
trafic international démente
l'information violente explosion cet
après midi en plein centre de téhéran
dans le quartier des ministères
de nombreuses ambulances sont sur les
lieux des groupes de manifestants se
seraient formées
on n'en sait pas plus pour l'instant
l'italie a honte de la sicile et les
siciliens ont honte de la mafia en tout
cas ceux qui ont manifesté aujourd'hui à
palerme à l'appel des trois centrales
syndicales italiennes pour protester
contre l'assassinât du général della
chiesa une grève générale de quatre
heures a été observée dans l'île le
successeur du héros de la lutte anti
terroriste italienne est arrivé
aujourd'hui dans la capitale sicilienne
pour prendre ses fonctions dès fonctions
et une succession bien lourde
le portrait du nouvel ennemi numéro un
de la mafia victor amant emmanuel de
brantes chaise que le successeur du
général dalla kiev est arrivé ce matin à
palerme il a dit quelques mots à la
télévision italienne
non je n'ai pas peur a dit des french
esque je suis venu à palerme pour
poursuivre l'action de dal acquise
j'espère que mes épaules seront assez
larges pour supporter cet héritage
particulièrement lourd
il est vrai qu'il est bien difficile de
succéder au général carlo alberto da la
pièce
le problème est évidemment de savoir de
quels moyens mais surtout de quel
pouvoir disposera le coq et des planches
est cela dit
des flèches est ce qu'on n'est pas
seulement préfet de palerme il est aussi
commissaire extraordinaire du
gouvernement chargé de coordonner la
lutte contre la mafia
non seulement sicile et sur tout le
territoire national
eh bien c'est exactement ce que
demandaient depuis longtemps le général
de la crise et il a fallu qu'on le tue
pour que le gouvernement italien
s'aperçoivent tout à coup que c'est
effectivement la bonne solution
ce matin à palerme il y à une grève
générale de quatre heures et une
manifestation syndicale
mais justement le préfet dé francesco ne
peut réussir que s'il reçoit l'appui
total des autorités locales et de la
population
ce ne sera pas facile en sicile on peut
difficilement devenir conseiller
régional ou conseiller municipal sans
être parrainé par la mafia quant à la
population elle a intérêt à observer
l'omerta c'est à dire la loi du silence
l'attentât de l'avenue de la bourdonnais
le 21 août dernier à paris aura fait
deux victimes
l'artificier bernard moreau ont
grièvement blessé en tentant de
désamorcer la bombe est décédé la nuit
dernière des suites de ses blessures
pinceaux sport maintenant est d'abord au
tennis avec une grande déception à
flushing meadow yannick noah a été
éliminé en 8e de finale éliminé par
l'australien warwick et cela en quatre
manches au profit de warwick donc 5 7 6
3 7 5 et 6 4
warwick l'australien et 55e au
classement mondial les championnats
d'europe d'athlétisme ont commencé
aujourd'hui à athènes
l'un des espoirs français l'un des seuls
dans ces épreuves est une femme chantal
rega qui doit courir le 400 m haies
brigitte duvauchelle nous la présente
regardez bien à droite de l'écran c'est
la chute cela se passait aux derniers
championnats d'europe à prague il y a
quatre ans à cause d'un mauvais passage
de relais chantal rega tombait et se
briser le fémur
elle semblait perdu pour l'athlétisme
français et pourtant elles représentent
aujourd'hui un espoir de monter sur le
podium
je pense que nous sommes en europe cinq
à six filles à avoir ce même objectif
il ya trois places donc il faudra se
bagarre et je ne je ne sous estime pas
du tout les les possibilités de mes
adversaires je sais que les athlètes de
l'ess les russes les gentilles et
l'allemande dents de lait seront
préparés vraiment très bien ces
championnats d'europe
et moi aussi d'ailleurs donc je suis
très confiante et et ça se jouera sur le
sur le terrain une carrière déjà
brillante pour cet athlète de 27 ans qui
était finaliste du 200 m jeux olympiques
de montréal et du 100 m à ceux de moscou
elle se situe dans le trio mondial du
400 m haies 1 elle vient de prouver
qu'elle était en forme ascendante en
pulvérisant le record de france en 55
secondes et 28 centièmes
chantal rega et net l'aide très sûr et à
l'occasion de ces championnats d'europe
elle est bien décidée à prouver qu'elle
est revenue au tout premier plan
une chance pour la france d'obtenir une
médaille le temps maintenant rapidement
philippe duez
oui ben pour les élèves qui vont rentrer
demain à l'école et bien le temps sera
assez instable est assez variable mais
le ciel sera tout de même moins nuageux
que nous le montre cette photographie
prise aujourd'hui à 14 heures seuls les
versants nord des massifs montagneux de
l'alsace aux alpes recevront peut-être
encore quelques pluies en corse il y
aura encore un petit résidus orageux
avec peut-être quelques averses partout
ailleurs ce sera essentiellement de
belles éclaircies
sauf en fin d'après midi ou une vague
nuageuse va encore pénétré sur le nord
ouest de la france dans le midi le ciel
va se dégager progressivement avec
l'arrivée du mistral et de la tramontane
et des vents seront assez forts dans le
golfe du lion côté températures elles
sont assez stable de l'ordre de 20
degrés dans la moitié nord et de l'ordre
de 24 degrés dans la moitié sud
demain c'est la sainte régine le soleil
se lève à 7h 16 et il se couchera à
20h20 un 3h15 jacques merlino demain
antenne 2010 avec philippe labro j'aurai
le plaisir de vous retrouver demain à 20
heures
bonne soirée sur antenne 2